a worsening economy in ecuador and
violence on the streets of its capital
quito
rising prices and shortages of food and
fuel have led to more than a week of
protests called by a powerful movement
of indigenous groups
[Music]
dozens of people have been injured in
the demonstrations calling for
government action
[Applause]
the national government has given us a
document with imprecise ideas in which
it states they have responded to our
demands despite the level of generality
and lack of political will shown towards
the indigenous movement of ecuador
thousands of indigenous ecuadorians have
taken part in the rallies although they
make up only a small part of the
country's near 18 million population
they have strong political influence
through the indigenous nationalities
confederation
amnesty international has accused the
government of repressing the protests
saying it's causing a human rights
crisis in ecuador
the president has extended a state of
emergency and is calling for calm
we are attending to the legitimate
demands of the citizens but their
response is more violence we cannot
allow a few violent people to prevent
millions of ecuadorians from working and
we will not allow people to be pitted
against people the defense minister says
the demonstrations are damaging
democracy and pledged to stop them
the indigenous movement is calling for
an indefinite strike
with no sign of compromise on either
side many fear the conflict could
escalate
julian wolf
al jazeera